The random variable will give you the number of outcomes in
an experiment the probability distribution.
also known as pmf will give you the probability of
an outcome within an experiment.
so, we now starting to see the full picture with the
Most important component in all of statistics and
probability Theory let's move on to this example.
And automobile parts manufacturer is sipping six lots of
components to their vendors.
6 containers
containing Auto Parts to their vendors
some components in the lots are defective. However, the number of
defects found that each lot is as follows. So box
number one or Lot number one has zero defects.
Box number two has two and so on. This is the table for
the probability distribution.
Any of these Lots can be selected randomly and shipped
to a vendor.
Let X be the random variable.
For the number of defects found in each slot. So it will
be the table or the column containing the number
of defects found in each box.
Similar to The Shear inflection example we looked at.
And the possible values of X are 0 1 and 2.
make sense
because you can either have zero defects.
one defect or two defects
they have like the company that counted defects
did not find anything more than two defects. So zero
one or two.
in these six events
six events correspond to the lots of containers
three have the result. Well, you know,
it's it's explaining this three halves the result or X is equal
to 0 so
X for this value is 0 x for this value is 0
x for this value is 0 x for this value is 2
X for this value is 2 X for this is equal to 1.
Okay, so now we know that random variable.
It's going to ask us what is the
probability distribution of x?
What is the probability distribution of x?
I'm going to jump right to the notation. I'm going to click on reveal answer.
I'm going to explain the notification to you.
Peter what PSP is the notation for probability
if you want to know the probability of something you write the letter p
Then the thing for what you want to measure is probably pass it between the
parentheses.
Here just focus on this part for a moment.
You're asking. What is the probability?
That the random variable X.
will have
zero defects
We already know that the random variable has.
This many defects for all six slots.
What is the probability that you would pick one randomly like one lot
randomly?
And there will be no defects.
David look again.
So this
term
probably of x equal to 0
Translates to the probability that Lot
1 or 3 or lot 6 have
been.
randomly shipped to the vendor
Like the wind like the vendor.
Would be unlucky and they would receive lot one last three or lot
six.
Excuse me. I was lucky.
because
I made a mistake lot one last three and
six have no defects. Let's say they were lucky.
And they would they would they would receive lot one lot through
lot six so they would get the shipment no defects.
Now they can sell it to the clients.
What is a probably that we there would be lucky.
This is the notation for probability. That's p.
Then we have the random variable.
We're asking what is it? Probably that X will be 0.
Well, then we know that probably we know how probably works.
You take the that the size of
the event.
divided by the size of the sample space
Size of the event divided by the sample space so we have
three lots that have no defects and we have six slots
in total.
Three divided by 6. That's 3.5.
Okay.
You can do some algebra divide.
The numerator numerator and denominator by 3
and we get 1 over 2.
also
This is equivalent to this.
So you're asking what is the probability?
That he will have zero defects.
I want you to be familiar with both types of notations this notation
here at the right.
This notation here at the left.
Okay, because they're both equivalent.
Now let's
continue. We haven't completed the probability distribution
of the random variable X.
This is when X the first one is for X when there are zero defects.
What is the probability distribution?
Or what is the probability rather when the random variable takes
some takes on the value one?
Like what is a probability that you would find a box?
with one effect
exactly one defect.
there will be similar notation for
For example up to one if the fact or up to
10 Defector up to 1180 facts, but right now we we considered
when exactly a precise value. What is
the probability that X will take on the value 1?
So you will find the Box.
And you would pick a box randomly and
one of them will have exactly one defect.
Well, then you asking for pot a lot number four.
Why Lot Number Four because Lot Number Four has exactly one
defect.
So we have one defect or one box out of
how many boxes six.
And of course by now, you should know the probability formula you take
the size of the event.
remember
here we have lots but we in probability we
call them events the boxes that this box is an event. This box
is an event Xbox, isn't it? Why is it called an event?
Because you're picking it randomly and you're sending it over. It's it's like
flipping a coin you're taking a chance when you pick
up something randomly, and you're not expecting the the box
to see what's inside.
You're taking a chance.
So we brings us to a question. What is it? Probably that you'd pick
up one of those bucks and they will have exactly one defect one out of
six.
Just like rolling the dice.
Zero point and you know, of course if you calculate this
or convert this fraction to decimal it gives you the point six seven.
and of course
x equals to same same story. What is the chance
or what is the probability that you would pick up two boxes?
And or you would pack pick up any box.
and
they will be exactly two defects. Well, since we have
two boxes where to defects that would be two for six and it
the answer is 0.3.